me as India I'm learning to rise above
if you catch me on a bad day it's a clap
back Charlotte is both at the same time
if that's possible because she will rise
above you whilst clapping back you will
not be left standing you'll be left
shaking oh gosh me as India trainers I
mean you can't even pan down right now
I'm wearing some beat up dirty air force
ones right now Charlotte would wear
heels for sure a love letter for both of
us both Charla and me
um were both quite intimate in that
sense me as India romance novel Queen
Charlotte gossip magazine I mean she
practically invented them especially in
Bridgeton the um those debutante balls
are basically Talk of the Town